hello everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on sql
basics for bigness by simpler
in this session we will learn about the
database
and the need for a database then we will
transition to
sql and see some basic sql queries after
knowing what a sql query is
we will see the features in application
subscript query
and then we will have a hand on some of
the basic sql queries
so hey everyone i am abhishar ruja from
simply learn
and welcome to this video on sql basics
for beginners
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon to now miss an update
let's start with database a database is
a vast collection of data
that is stored and retrieved
electronically from a system
in today's world data has become the new
oil which has mandate companies and
businesses
to rely on an excellent database to
store the vast amounts of data
every millisecond the tech giants are
accumulating vast amounts of data
that need to be stored the database
comes with features to update and
effortlessly manipulate data and not
only that
these database provider companies ensure
the data to be safe and secure
they also provide tools to extract
useful information
to help the companies make meaningful
decisions
after knowing about the database let's
see how sql communicates with the
database to get desired results
sql stands for structured query language
the structured query language
is the standard language used by
database operators and developers to
carry out different operations
from manipulating updating and
retrieving data from relational
databases
now let us see how we write a basic
query
there's a customer table with columns
customer id
customer name age gender date of
purchase
address item and price and we need to
extract the customer id and customer
name
from this table so we will write a query
select customer id comma customer name
from customers
semicolon when we will execute the query
in my sequel workbench we will get the
desired result that is the output table
with customer id and customer name this
is how
we write a query to extract the
information from the database
we'll see some more queries as the
session proceeds
now we'll see what the features of sql
are
sql lets you access any information
stored in a relational database
with sql queries data is extracted from
the database
in a very efficient way the structured
query language
is compatible with all database systems
from oracle
ibm to microsoft and it doesn't require
much coding to manage databases now we
will see
applications of sql sql is used to
create a database
define its structure implement it and
lets you perform many functions
sql is also used for maintaining an
already existing database
sql is a powerful language for entering
data modifying data
and extracting data in a database sql is
extensively used
as a client-server language to connect
the front-end with the back-end
thus supporting the client-server
architecture sql when deployed as data
control language
dcl helps protect your database from
unauthorized access
after knowing sql with its features and
applications
let's go through some basic queries in
sql
that is ddl data definition language
dml data manipulation language dcl
data control language tcl transaction
control language
ddl or data definition language consists
of the sql commands that can be used to
define the database schema
let's see ddl commands create command is
used to create the database
or its objects like table index function
views stored procedure and triggers
drop is used to delete objects from the
database
truncate is used to remove all records
from a table
alter is used to alter the structure of
the database
dml or data manipulation language
consists of the sql commands that deals
with the manipulation of data
present in the database insert into
command is used to insert data
into a table update is used to update
existing data
within a table delete is used to delete
records from a database table
select this command helps you to select
the attribute
based on the condition described by the
workflows
tcl or transaction control language
these commands
deals with the transaction within the
database commit commands commit
a transaction rollback command rollbacks
a transaction
in case of any error occurs save point
it sets a save point within a
transaction
set transaction it specify
characteristics for the transaction
dcl or data control language it consists
of the commands such as grant and revoke
which mainly deals with the rights
permissions and other controls of the
database system
grant command gives user access
privileges to database
revoke it withdraw user success
privileges given by
using the grant command now we'll have
hands on some basic queries
in my sequel work match if getting your
learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we will see some basic queries
executing in my
sql workbench so we'll start
and first query will run will be use
sys that is the database
command is used to select the database
in which
we want to create or manipulate any data
now we'll see another command that would
create a table
now we will add attributes to the
customer table that would be the columns
first would be the customer id and we
will
act at it as a primary key
the next attribute we would add would be
customer name
customer underscore name
and its data type would be very care
next attribute would be h
within data type
next attribute would be gender
with character data type
next we will add as date of purchase
with date data type now we'll add
another attribute that would be address
with data type where
next we would write the attribute item
that would be the item purchased with
data type where care
next would be the price
okay for price we will make it as
float
and let's shift this to next line
and now we'll execute this command
yeah you can see that the table is
created
now we have to insert values into it
for that we'll write a command insert
into customers
values and
i have all the reports written in the
notepad
so i will copy these
and paste it here these are 20 records
like all the attributes they are in the
order
so we have written all the records in
the order only
like customer id that would be 101
customer name that would be joseph
age that would be 22 gender may
date of purchase this is the date of
purchase
address pune item that is vegetable
purchased
price that is 80. so now we will run
this command
and all these records
they would be inserted into the table
and these are 20 commands
20 reports
you can see insert into customer values
the command has been executed and they
have been inserted into the table
now we'll see the table
for that we'll write the command select
star
from customers
here you can see the table in the output
grid
okay i will make sure you will see the
whole table
with all the 20 quotes
yeah you can see all the 20 reports they
have been inserted
now you see another command
and for that we would just get the
output as customer id and customer name
in the output grid
for that we'll write the command select
customer id coma
customer name
from customers semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we will get both the columns
customer id and customer name
in our output grid
now let's see another command that would
be drop the drop
command just removes the component from
the database
so we will write drop
table and table name
that would be customers and semicolon
and we will execute this command
now the table has been removed from the
database
to verify whether the table has been
removed from the database or not we will
run a command
select star from
customers semicolon and execute this
command
and what we will get is select start
from customers
error code table says customers doesn't
exist
the table has been removed from the
database so the drop command worked here
now we don't have any table that is the
customer table has been dropped from the
database
so we have to create that table again
so we'll go at the top okay
yeah and we'll create the table again
and we'll insert all the reports again
into the table
both the commands have run now we will
run this command to see whether the
table has been created and the reports
have been inserted into the table or not
both commands have worked
now we'll see another command that would
be truncate
the truncate command just manages all
the records from the table
truncate table
table name
semicolon and just run this command
the command has been executed now we'll
see
yeah you can see that all the records
from the table has been vanished
so the truncate command worked here now
to carry other operations we have to
insert all the reports again into the
table
we'll do that we'll again go
upwards and run this command
insert into customers values and
all the reports and will execute this
command
and that command has been executed and
all the records
are again in the table so we'll run this
command and check it
yeah you can see all the reports then
set it into the table
now let's see another command that would
be alter
alter command is used to update any
record into the table you will see
folder table
table name that is customers
and now what we should do uh okay
we'll drop the column h from the table
so right command drop
column each
semicolon i'll run this command
the command has been executed and now
we'll check
whether the each column has been dropped
or not
select star from customers
semicolon and we will execute this
command
yeah you can see the age column has been
dropped off the table
so the alter command has been executed
successfully
okay so now we'll see another thing
like if you want to comment something
during the execution
you can do that just write two minus
signs
and the text
this would be the comment and you can
also use
slash star and that
text inside it and star
and slash so this is also the
comment section you can write comment
with this syntax or with the syntax they
both work
now we'll see another command that would
be update
this is also used to manipulate data in
the table
to update any record into the table
so we will write update table name
that would be customers
and what we should update okay we will
update our record
we will change the customer name and
address
and we have the primary key as customer
id so we'll use that
so update customers set
customer name
equal to
james coma
and address
to boston
where
customer id equal to
one zero one okay
you can see here in the table one zero
one
customer id the customer name is joseph
and the address is phony
we have updated command and we will
execute it
let's see okay okay we have an error
here
oh yeah that's correct we will execute
this command
here the command has been executed
successfully and now we
check the table with the command select
star from customers
semicolon
you can see the row has been updated the
customer name is
james here and the address is boston so
the command has
been executed successfully now we'll see
another command that would be delete
so delete command is used to delete any
particular record
for any particular row so we'll write
the command
delete from
customers where
customer id
equal to one zero two semicolon
so the second row that is with customer
id 102 that would be deleted
and we'll execute this command
now we'll check into the table
yeah you can see the record has been
deleted
now we'll see distinct command that is
used to return different
values so we will write command
select distinct
and the column name for which we want
different values
to be in the output grid we select
address
from customers
and we will execute this command
yeah these are the address so these are
the cities in the address
which are different and which are unique
and we have get that through the
distinct command
now we will see minimum command minimum
command is used to
get the records or get the data that is
minimum of all the data
so for that we will write the syntax
select minimum
like min in bracket we will write the
attribute name or the column name
for which we want the data to be minimum
as less price
this would be the attribute name
from customers
so we will execute this command and
what we would see is that 60 would be
the last price
like the customer table they have the
column price
and in that we all we have all the
prices and from that
the minimum price is 60 and we have get
it at
less price similarly we have the maximum
command
to get the maximum amount from the
column
we will use the maximum command
select max in bracket
we will write the attribute name as
max price
from customers
and we will execute this command and
what we get is 3400
is the maximum price from the price
column
now we'll see another command that would
be count
count command it returns the number of
rows according to the query
so we'll run the query and see like how
it works
we'll write select count
and the attribute name that would be
a customer id
customer id
from customers semicolon
and when we'll run this command we will
get
19 as a result that is it counted the
number of customer ids that is 19
in the table now you'll see another
command
that would be average so it just gets
the average of the
numbers and how we do it let the query
select avg
and the attribute name for which you
want the average
from table name
semicolon and we'll execute this command
and we'll get the average of the price
from the customers table now if you want
to add up all the prices from the
customer table
you can use the command sum so how will
execute that command
select sum in bracket we will write the
attribute name
that would be price from
customers semicolon and we'll run this
command
and we'll get the sum of the prices from
the customer table
now we'll see their command where
command is used to filter records
uh let's say through syntax so we will
write
select star
from customers
where
address uh yeah we will
wear address equal to
pune semicolon
and then we'll run this command
and yeah this is the table we will get
telecodes
with addresses spooning
so this is the functioning of wear
command
now we'll see group by command that is
used to
just group the number of rows that have
the same values
we will see it through the syntax
like we will write select
count attribute name that would be
customer id
comma address
from table name
and group by accordingly with
address
here the comma will not come yeah this
is the command
select count customer id comma address
from customers group by address
when we will execute this command yeah
we will get this table
that would be these are the different
addresses
and these are the number of times the
number of persons who live in this
address with the count
with respect to customer ids
now let's see having close with the help
of an example only
select count
attribute name that would be customer id
comma address
from table name that will be customers
group by address
having count
customer id
greater than unit 3 4
3 2 3
semicolon and then we will execute this
command
and you can see
the output we have got through this
command that is group by command
close this and when we have added having
close
having count customer id greater than
three
we just got the customer id count with
four
now we'll see another command that is
order by
select star from table name that is
customers
and we will order this output by address
semicolon
we have got the output with respect to
the address
the address has been assigned
alphabetically here with that we have
come to the end of this session
i hope it was interesting and
informative if you liked it please let
us know in the comment section
also do subscribe to our channel and
stay tuned for more from simply now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here